[Music]
few people in Hollywood have ever lived
with more passion or had more fun than
Burt Reynolds it showed on the big
screen and it showed with the ladies he
loved I always used to think that my
whole appeal if I had any of you at all
was that I didn't take myself very
seriously
while Burt says he didn't take himself
seriously women certainly did his first
wife was laughing star Judy carne he
then had a high-profile romance with
singer Dinah Shore but the one woman he
called the love of his life was Sally
Field who was a frequent co-star if we
weren't lost on a desert island together
I remember when I brought up her name to
be in Spokane advantage and everybody
said we want to get her for if she's
that sexy and I said you don't
understand talent is sexy truthfully I
don't think she wanted to marry me you
know well I don't think she thought I
was so good you know this is not a good
bit today Sally says of Burt's passing
quote there are times in your life that
are so indelible they never fade away
they stay alive even 40 years later my
years with Burt never leave my mind
he will be my history and my heart for
as long as I live rest buddy during his
marriage to Loni Anderson they were once
considered Hollywood's golden couple but
when they split they became tabloid
targets but in a very unusual Hollywood
moved the day their divorce was settled
the two held hands and addressed the
press outside of the courthouse I'm very
very happy that we were able to sell
papers for a year and a half why that
doesn't translate to a lot of money I
don't know
you